this video is currently sponsored by
keeps but more about that later on in
the video hey 42 here if we've learned
anything over the last few years it's
that the world we live in is far from
predictable
of course there are some constants fast
food burgers don't ever look like the
pictures on the menu toast always lands
butter side down
and men named tiny are never small
then there's the greatest certainty of
all death
but it turns out not even that is
totally predictable
for example at most funerals you don't
really expect to be burying anyone other
than the person in the coffin but from
zimbabwe to kenya to china there have
been multiple cases of people being
struck and killed by lightning
whilst attempting a funeral
suddenly instead of just mourning one
person seven other people who you cared
for are gone
that would be a shocking experience for
anyone
but you still wouldn't be nearly as
surprised as the 2 000 mourners who are
said to have perished at one particular
burial in this case though the blame
couldn't be laid at the feet of mother
nature instead it was all thanks to
instructions from the deceased himself
who commanded that everyone attending
his funeral be slain
i'm guessing they didn't put that on the
invitation the year was 12 27 and the
man orchestrating mass murder from
beyond the grave
was genghis khan
warrior ruler of the mongol empire
now i'd like to take a moment to talk
about hair loss i've had people close to
me start to lose their hair as early as
their 20s and it's always been an
upsetting experience if you're in the
same boat then you're not alone did you
know two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 but the
best thing you can do to prevent hair
loss is take the initiative now and do
something about it whilst you've still
got hair left i like keeps because it
makes treatment super easy by delivering
your hair loss medication every three
months so you can say goodbye to awkward
doctor visits and waiting in pharmacy
checkout lines
there's a reason that keeps has more
five-star reviews in any of its
competitors and hundreds of thousands of
men trust them for their hair loss
prevention medication if you're like me
you're probably not ready to lose your
hair just yet but prevention is key the
faster you act the faster you'll see
results and the sooner you start using
keeps the more hair you'll save
so if you're noticing that you're losing
your hair do something about it for a
limited time go to keeps.com
42 or click the link in the description
to receive 50 off your first order you
see genghis khan was rather keen on
keeping the location of his final
resting place under wraps
and legend has it that the mourners at
his funeral were killed to stop anyone
giving the game away for extra security
the soldiers who slaughtered the
mourners
were themselves murdered by yet more
soldiers
it was absolute carnage
genghis carnage
i'll see myself out
all his bloodshed had one objective to
keep the location of the great khan's
tomb hidden at all costs if you think
that's a bit of an extreme way of going
about things remember historians believe
genghis khan was responsible for the
deaths of about 40 million people whilst
building his vast empire
in that context 2000 dead mourners a
handful of gravediggers and a couple of
hundred soldiers
was a fairly merciful day at the office
genghis khan was born into a nomadic
mongolian tribe in may 1162. under the
name temujin
it's said that he came into this world
clutching a blood clot in his hand an
auspicious sign that apparently
indicated he was to be a great future
leader
would go on to fulfill this prophecy and
then some becoming one of the most
significant and influential leaders the
world has ever seen
despite many early hardships
temujin's father a tribal chief was
poisoned by his enemies when tomujin was
just nine years old the young boy tried
to take over leadership of the tribe but
instead of claiming the title of chief
he was cast out into the wilderness
along with his mother and siblings
for years he and his family scavenged
and hunted to survive without the
protection of a tribe
then as a teenager temujin was kidnapped
and fought into slavery
he eventually escaped these bonds going
on to unify the mongol tribes and
eventually be declared chingus khan or
universal ruler in 1206.
genghis khan created an empire so vast
that at its peak it covered most of
eurasia some 23 million square
kilometers for some perspective the
empire today would cover most if not all
of russia and china
as well as hungary bulgaria poland
kazakhstan the kurg's republic
uzbekistan tajikistan korea burma turkey
india iraq and iran
that's a pretty impressive game of risk
so given he was such a big deal why and
how is the final resting place of the
great khan
not known
elvis presley was just a king and we
know where he's buried
well it turns out the y part wasn't
particularly unique or mysterious being
buried at an undisclosed location was a
custom in genghis khan's tribe so he was
just following his own tradition
but the how part is a considerably more
complicated story
genghis khan died during a campaign
against the chinese kingdom of west
india
but the exact cause of his death
is a matter of speculation
he may have been killed during battle or
died from a wound that he'd suffered
during the fall from his horse some
months before
there are also theories to suggest that
he was stabbed to death by a kidnapped
princess
not your typical disney movie is it
whatever the cause of his demise a
morning army brought genghis khan's body
back to mongolia to bury it in all
likelihood somewhere close to his
birthplace
or did they
the trouble is this entire story is full
of contradictions for example a
competing legend says genghis khan
wasn't brought back from china at all
and that the coffin said to contain his
body
was actually empty
the truth is this is mostly guesswork
the first rule of secret burial club
is nobody talks about secret burial club
and the army knew exactly how to stop
tongues from wagging
the story goes that in addition to the
mourners they killed anyone and even any
animal that was encountered on route to
the burial site
after the burial one thousand horses
were reportedly brought in to trample
the ground removing any trace of the
grave
other accounts go even further
describing how a river was diverted to
hide the tomb that might sound a little
far-fetched but genghis khan wants to
use exactly this tactic to flood the
capital of western's yard so
it isn't outside the realms of
possibility
the great khan remains a revered figure
in mongolian culture his image is
widespread throughout the country
adorning banknotes staring out from
portraits that hang on walls and gazing
across the landscape from large statues
and monuments
it's probably for this reason that most
locals have respected his wishes to be
left in peace
well that and the rumored belief that
his grave is cursed and the world will
end if it's ever found
either way attempt to locate genghis
khan's grave have mostly come from
foreigners and they've been at it for
centuries
most investigations have used clues in
historical texts to narrow down the
search area
but as technology has improved
tools like satellites have been utilized
to search for any man-made disturbances
or anomalies that could be used to
pinpoint the tomb
the national geographic field project
valley of the khans recruited ordinary
people to hunt through satellite imagery
in search of likely burial sites
ten thousand volunteers identified
around 2.5 million points of interest
across the mongolian landscape
these were then whittled down by expert
eyes leaving 100 sites that were
physically investigated by a team on the
ground
but even though this technique has
helped to solve other missing person
cases with google earth
genghis khan
was not destined to be one of them
the truth is
the two might never be found
mongolia covers an area of more than 1.5
million square kilometers and it's
sparsely populated with very little
infrastructure
making it difficult to mount any kind of
large-scale search
the country is also made up of huge
expanses of mountains and grasslands
where any grave is unlikely to be
unearthed by accident in order to focus
the search it makes sense to hone in on
ketty province where the great khan was
born and where many experts believe he's
probably buried
but this
small search area
it's almost the same size as austria
that's like looking for a schnitzel in a
haystack
another problem tomb hunters face is
that they don't really know what they're
looking for
empires come and go and before the
mongol empire there was a zhong new
empire
genghis khan was said to believe these
rulers were his forefathers and even
copied imagery from the dynasty in his
royal designs
if the graves as young new kings give us
an inkling of what the great khan's tomb
could look like
we're searching for a timber-lined room
at a depth of 20 meters
containing genghis khan's remains and
various artifacts to be taken to the
afterlife
these artifacts are expected to include
treasures from across one of the
greatest empires history has ever known
so you can understand why interest
remains high
at the surface above the tomb a square
of stones would identify the grave but
since genghis khan wasn't keen on being
found it's unlikely stone markers would
have been used
many of the clues as to the whereabouts
of the burial place come from ancient
texts but these can be as conflicting as
twitter posts about donald trump
on one hand we have the legend of 1000
horses trampling earth above great
khan's grave
that story suggests genghis khan is
buried somewhere flat like the plains
but in other accounts he's buried at the
top of a sacred peak known as birken
kaldun a part of the kente mountain
range where he once hid from enemies and
swore to return to upon his death
later in his life he even declared this
area off limits to the general public
strengthening the idea that this is a
potential location for his grave the
area was permanently guarded by soldiers
with orders to kill anyone who wasn't a
member of the royal family which is how
the region earns the title the great
taboo
as you probably know the second great
taboo happened in 1962
when someone first had the idea to put
pineapple on pizza
these days access to the holy mountain
isn't much easier than it was back then
women aren't allowed and anyone trying
to confirm whether the great khan is
buried on the slopes of burke and caldon
will be disappointed the mountain and
its surroundings have been declared a
unesco world heritage site the khan
ketty strictly protected area
so researchers are no longer allowed to
dig there
following the pattern of wild historical
inconsistency
yet another ancient record describes how
court officials traveled from a
mausoleum at genghis khan's palace to
the burial site on a daily basis
in order to carry out ceremonial
practices for the dead if that were true
the whole story about mourners being
killed by soldiers who were in turn
killed by soldiers who were killed by
more soldiers
and so on until nobody knew anything
would be a total fabrication but it
would also mean that the gravesite was
near enough to the palace to be traveled
to within a day
that's been the big hope since 2004 when
a promising discovery was made that
brought us closer to the truth than
anything else that has come before it
wasn't quite one foot in the grave but
it was potentially one foot in the
graveyard a team of japanese and
mongolian archaeologists unearthed what
they believed to be genghis khan's
palace constructed around the year 1200.
the remains of the structure are located
on a grassland around 150 miles to the
east of ullan battle the capital of
mongolia porcelain found at the site was
successfully dated to genghis khan's
time and the surrounding area fits the
description recorded by a messenger from
china in 1232. if as scholars believe
the burial site would have been located
somewhere near the palace then the
archaeologists may be onto something
for now the chances of locating genghis
khan's tomb seem relatively slim
mongolia is simply too big
and the clues that have filtered down
through history to sparse but
one thing's for sure
if the burial site is ever discovered it
will be one of the greatest
archaeological finds in history
[Music]
thanks for watching